-Ah, Cecily, it is great
to see you.
-Hello.
-Cecily, congrats!
-Great to see you.
-Congrats, your first Emmy nom.
Come on, how does it feel?
How'd you find out?
-It's nuts.
I was home and I sort of --
I was, like, waiting around.
I knew they were coming out
that day,
but I'm never expecting it,
so far from it.
And, like, normally,
I would get -- Every other year
people are really nice, but
they'd be like, "I'm so sorry."
You're like, "Wha-- I don't --
I appreciate that, but, like,
I was feeling fine today."
So then I got a text from
our publicist, Lauren Rodsman,
and she just said,
"Congrats, you were nominated"
or something,
and I was like, "For what?
What does that mean?"
And then I really had to --
I did a lot of digging.
I had my roommate, Kevin --
he's my quarantine buddy.
And I texted him,
"I think I was nominated."
And then he ran out of the room.
And so it took me like a day
to fully believe it.
-You're like, "As a show
or as a cast?
Did I write something?
Or is it a song?"
-Right, the show gets nominated,
what is it that this is for?
-You crushed it.
-Costumes at home?
-Oh, the at-home shows,
you were great on that as well.
-Those were some of the hardest
we've worked, I think.
I had to learn all
these weird technical programs.
I'm 180. I'm like Tom Cruise
in "Interview with the Vampire."
-Oh, no, come on.
-That old when it comes
to technology.
I miss the train.
I miss that window.
So trying to learn
all of these things.
And they sent us,
like, a full studio.
I have all these mikes
and a full green screen
that we had to hang
from our stairway.
-That's right.
-Yeah, so that was --
it was really crazy.
And then doing our
own hair and makeup --
My friend Kevin made
beautiful props, though.
I had him.
-Is Kevin going to make you
props for the Emmys?
How is that going to work?
-He's going to have to.
He'll be the only one
with me again. Yeah.
I don't know how that works.
You know, we're in
this asterisk year.
I don't have to wear Spanx,
I don't think.
-[ Laughs ]
You know, it's interesting.
We were doing research,
and I saw that
"Late Night" was
your first talk show.
It was the first season of "SNL"
for you.
-Yes.
-See, I knew back then.
I knew, see.
-Wow, yeah, yeah.
-I was very prescient.
I knew that you were gonna
get the Emmy nom.
-I think you said it.
-Your ninth season.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Sorry, my house phone
is ringing.
I don't know
who would even have this.
-You just got nominated for
another Emmy.
That's what we're calling.
[ Laughter ]
-They're calling on
the land line.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, we just
wanted to get your reaction
while we're Zooming, yeah.
Does your dad still suggest
characters to you?
-Yeah, so, I mean, he
definitely -- it's still in him.
He tries to control it
a little bit.
But I have -- Actually, I lost
my wonderful cousin Owen
to glioblastoma in January,
and I wound up at the start of
corona, really, March,
I connected with
his neurooncologist from Duke
who was, like, the most
outspoken body man,
Dr. Friedman,
and he sends like --
we're all on a group text, and
he sends like 76 texts a day,
editorial, news articles
and then some editorial,
and he's always like,
"Now, I don't think
you want to use this for 'SNL.'"
So, like, Henry's my new --
-Yeah.
-I'm like, "Henry, aren't you
busy right now?"
[ Laughter ]
-Your characters are so good.
Are they based off
of real people?
Where do you pull from?
Like the girl at the party?
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, Girl at the Party
started off
just kind of making fun
of myself.
And then it was kind of like
the beginning of social media,
really being soapboxy,
I feel like,
and I remember this girl
on Facebook
when Obama won his second term.
She wrote something like,
"Wow, everybody's really happy,
and that makes me
really, really sad."
It was just such an insane thing
to say.
-Do Jost and Che know everything
you're going to say there?
-No, so, I love now --
the characters that we do are
pretty loose.
And Colin's -- I'm like,
"Colin, do you mind
if I throw up on you?"
And he's like,
"Yeah, that sounds great."
[ Laughter ]
-That was unbelievable.
That was so good.
-He loves it. He loves it.
-He loves being thrown up on.
-He does.
He let himself be dunked on
at the home show.
But I think, like, what's nice
about the characters is
I really do feel like I get
a chance to kind of try to
make them laugh, if I can.
There was, like, a Cathy Ann
we did once,
and I said Mitch McDonald's --
that's what I call him --
and Che kind of laughed
and said, "Mitch McDonald's?"
And I went, "Yeah!
You don't know Mitch McDonald,
you're gonna run 'Update'?"
or something like that.
There's always, like, moments.
I think that's the best place
for being a little loose
and getting to improvise
and making those guys laugh.
-I love that voice.
Already I'm laughing at it.
Break a leg at the Emmys.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-I hope to see you
in person soon.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
Cecily Strong, everybody.